♪♪
♪ Girl, it ain't no lie
just look deep into my eyes ♪
♪ You're perfect and I think
you should know ♪
♪ You should know ♪
♪ That you don't need
no lipstick ♪
♪ You don't need no blush ♪
♪ 'Cause you've got
that inner natural glow ♪
♪ Magazines say that
you're whack ♪
♪ Girl, don't believe them ♪
♪ Just leave that
tabloid trash on the rack ♪
♪ Girl, don't you read them ♪
♪ You're beautiful
and who cares what they think ♪
♪ Now wash that loving face off
in the sink ♪
♪ In the sink, girl ♪
♪ Girl, you don't
need makeup ♪
♪ You're perfect
when you wake up ♪
♪ Just walk around
like that all day ♪
♪ Wipe that goop off
of your face ♪
♪ I'll take you
to a special place ♪
♪ It's something that
I've got to say ♪
♪ Wipe it off (whoo)
wipe it off (yeah) ♪
♪ Wipe it off (let's go, girl)
wipe it off ♪
♪ Ho-ho-ho-hold up, girl
we spoke too soon ♪
♪ With this whole
no makeup tune ♪
♪ We kinda changed our mind
on the makeup thing ♪
♪ You'll be the
hottest girl in the nation ♪
♪ With just a touch
of foundation ♪
♪ Girl, I can't be seen with
the ghost from "The Ring" ♪
♪ I didn't know that your lashes
were so stubby and pale ♪
♪ Just a little mascara
and you'll look female ♪
♪ Please listen, girl
what we're trying to say ♪
♪ Just get up an hour earlier ♪
♪ And you can make yourself
much girlier (girlier) ♪
♪ Much girlier ♪
♪ Girl, you don't
need makeup ♪
♪ You're perfect
when you wake up ♪
♪ Just don't go outside
like that, okay ♪
♪ Just a little makeup
some natural looking makeup ♪
♪ What more do I have to say ♪
♪ Just put it on ♪
♪ Put it on ♪
I'm trying.
♪ Just put it on
put it on (sing!)♪
♪ Na-na-na, na-na-na
na-na-na-na, na-na ♪
that's not enough, girl♪
More?
♪ Na-na-na, na-na-na ♪
♪ Na-na-na-na, na-na
na-na-na, na-na-na ♪
♪ Na, na! ♪
Girl, I wanna
get real with you.
I got a lot of regrets
in my life.
I regret missing
my father's funeral
to audition for
"The Voice."
I regret being high
when my niece was born.
But most of all,
I regret telling you
not to wear makeup.
That's on me.
But what's on you is
hopefully more makeup.
See, it's like I tore up
the shag carpet
assuming there were
hardwood floors underneath.
But it turn out to be
just dirty linoleum.
These are just
metaphors, girl.
But they are about
your face.
♪ Girl, you do need makeup
lots and lots of makeup ♪
♪ Think of a clown
and then work your way back ♪
♪ You are great
except your face, girl ♪
♪ So don't take off
your makeup ♪
♪ Wear it when
you sleep and swim ♪
♪ We met someone else
we're out ♪♪